sumemos estos dos números mixtos bueno
como a mí me gusta hacerlo es primero
dividir
estos números mixtos en su parte entera
más su fracción entonces lo primero que
yo hago es escribir este 2 y 513 a vos
como 12 más 5 13 a vos y luego hago lo
mismo con el segundo número mixto separo
el entero de la fracción así es que aquí
tenemos que sumar 7 más
6 13 a vos están de acuerdo conmigo en
que este número mixto es igual a esta es
una verdad lo siguiente que me gusta
hacer a mí es sumar primero los enteros
este y este y después sumar las
fracciones entonces lo que yo haría
sería sumar 2 más 7 y después sumar 5
treceavos y
613 a vos ahora 27 son exactamente igual
a 9 y de esta suma de fracciones lo que
tenemos como tienen un denominador común
las podemos sumar muy fácilmente y vamos
a tener como denominador 13 y como el
numerador tenemos 56 pero 56 es 11 y
bueno 9 enteros más 11 13 a vos es
exactamente igual al número mixto 9 y 11
13 a vos